see ya
hello all and welcome to another video
for total war Warhammer I am Joey Dalton
and I'm joined by Darren McNally in this
let's play Darren what are we doing this
time
so we're playing as the chaos warriors
in this let's play as we have a very
special announcement to make
that's right we do the chaos warriors
race pack will now not only be free to
you if you pre-order but it will also be
free for everyone who buys the game in
the first week of release as an early
adopter bonus yep so if you have
pre-ordered already you'll be able to
preload the game to be the first to play
it on May 24th but if you hold off the
chaos warriors will be available for the
first week after launch free of charge
so if you want more details on that
check the link in the description or
check out the total Warhammer steam page
right so we're fighting at high pass and
we're playing as chaos as we mentioned
and we're against the dwarves and just
this lovely unit here these are the
dragon augers and very cute very little
very small in comparison to the dragon
ogre chaga Wow so it's lightning yeah it
looks really good be kind of electrical
pulses around it looks really and it
sounds really good as well actually real
deep bass to him but that he's dwarfed
in comparison compared to Kolok
sun-eater one of the legendary Lords
that you can play us in the campaign if
you're playing as chaos he actually has
a bonus for having dragon ogres on
shoggoths he can recruit them at 15% the
costs and 10% the cost for the dragon
ogres
yeah the sun-eater and the star crusher
he is I mean he's as we'll see in this
playthrough he's really really powerful
and having those guys in your army it's
actually really good bonus to have to
have any kind of upkeep I don't have any
negative upkeep on them because they're
quite expensive they're quite rare so to
have them in this army like this you
know you're dealing with a high tier
powerful army we've also got at the back
there the chaos warriors with great
weapons and the Chosin here with great
weapons as well I flanked on the Left we
have a sorcerer of the metal variation
or the metal or so chaos warriors they
can actually play with different sources
of different lowers I think metal fire
and death there are some of the ones we
also have a Manticore flying up there
and down here we have the cast Knight
lenses you're gonna be doing some sneaky
tactics yeah so that we're actually
fighting uphill on this bottle it's
gonna be quite tricky and we have the
Dwarven army up here on top of the hill
so tonight
sorry sneaky tactics but obviously they
don't have cavalry themselves so we can
you know bring our cavalry round up
behind them on the girl have to do some
flanking charges it should be good well
you have a lot of fast units compared to
the torques we have practically no
fasteners at all they have really slow
even the Slayers which we'll see in a
minute in their room info step panel it
says fast right yeah Oh at these guys
here really cool the iron drapes with
the troll hammer torpedoes and that
they're meant to take down like a large
monstrous infantry so they'll be good
against the the shag off and the dragon
ogres as well as the cannons the Slayers
in the back and the flame comes it's
worth mentioning this is just it look
quick debug mode to look at their army
they'll actually deploy it a little bit
different to this but I just thought
it'd be interesting to see what we were
up against on top of this hill and so
here we are this is the kind of gameplay
so obviously we're not playing this
right now we're looking back on the
gameplay that I captured at the time but
to kind of appease the people who want
to see cool zoom ins and cool cinematic
shots
I've also interlaced the video with the
replay shot so for those who don't know
in Warhammer after battle is done you
can use you back the replay and you can
simply hide the UI repress in K and that
removes the flags in the gameplay UI and
then we're allowed to put the camera
down and see the gameplay as it unfolds
both from the gameplay and cinematic
perspective the timeline stays the same
so what you're seeing is all in
real-time as well so hopefully that will
let you guys have a real nice zoom in of
all the action and some of the
higher of gameplay choices that I've
made some of the more brutal fights
punches on I really wanna say yeah so so
we saw some dudes for fly back all the
way down the mountain getting hit by a
cannon so already the Dorgan artillery
is firing on me they're perched a little
bit further up on the hill than we were
in the debug mode and just see I'm just
sending everyone forward we just have a
long plot in March of this film till we
get there and the snow and the hill to
slow your troops down so they are
running as fast as we can you can see
them just getting thrown back and I'm
really have to try and take as few
losses as I can until I got there don't
want to send them all off by themselves
either I trying to keep them all
together and so have to kind of keep a
steady march earth when there's off so
do you have any kind of strategy for
this because you you have some making up
to do for your win-loss record for us
Aaron that's true well I did beat
Lionheart so you know I won the last one
okay but it in terms of this battle um
my strategy genre leads to move forward
with a kind of a double line split into
a single line and then half cavalry go
around the edges and I've concentrated
all my monsters infantry kind of on the
flanks as well off the infantry so I
have chaos spawn over on the right which
will zoom in a bit later as well
and I have my dragon overs on the left
hopefully we can just kind of punch
through and then have the cavalry come
around just a massive envelopment as
long as my center holds I love all the
dwarf and ruins kind of scattered around
the battlefield as well yeah this map is
really beautiful it's set up and then
kind of norsk in regions and there's
some dorvan Cara so I like to think that
you know they're they're kind of holding
back the chaos invasion as best as they
can before we move in on their north so
it's worth mentioning that Kolak is
fully upgraded here in custom battle
legendary Lords are fully upgrade it's
all the spells he's active that means
he's like fully upgrade fully tapped out
on a skill tree yes one of his the quest
battles is actually to get star fresher
which he doesn't start with when you
played
so as you can see he does have it here
so there we go the shag off has made its
way through the Dragon ogres are coming
in the same kinds of firing in the
background and the the iron breakers are
throwing their glass and charges towards
them as well so straight away it's like
a massive ditch fight up there the
Slayers are digging into my guys as well
which is gonna be a bit rough on the
monsters infantry but Joey actually
hasn't seen this bottom yet at all she's
watching this back for the first time so
I've got some surprises in there for her
as well as you guys so we can see that
they have a jar of llama as well now
what can take down a jar gonna
manticores pretty good yeah we'll send
that after it hopefully they do good I
will catch her put that later the things
are going pretty well I mean he's Kolak
is just smashing through dwarfs at the
moment is you know taking a bit of
damage they're throwing a lot of things
Adam I just used a final transmutation
there from my wizard which is a direct
damage spell and actually overcast it
which kind of increases the amount the
cost that those were gives me a 50%
chance of miss passing basically that's
just like a direct damage spell that
lasts for about 20 seconds I love the
flavor text for it is the wizard
unleashes a hail of magical energy
transmitting his foes into unliving
golden statues it's it's quite great
yeah so here you can see the chaos
spawned the blasting charges are
absolutely devastating there you have so
many of them the iron breaks and there's
some miners units as well miners with
blasting charges second
my man took was going to town on the
gyrocopter and it's actually broken it's
running away we've got a beautiful
charge here from the chaos Lance's as
well yeah it's funny because Kolok is so
massive especially compared to a torch
they're very very brave and Hardy folk
to even attempt to take them on so they
have quite a few Slayers units we're
just kind of bad for you in in a couple
of ways you get some larger units in
there yeah just that spell that's going
off there that is the Gehenna is golden
hounds
it's a vortex well last about 13 seconds
and it costs no means of magic again
that's the metal sorcerer just hanging
back passing spies where he can summons
the spirit so that's the blasting charge
is just going off in the distance launch
them up up blobs of infantry and just
completely records my Manticore came
down from this church that's it
yes I'm fine I'm not gonna lie it I kind
of do really well against these guys
we're just like pushing lay into them
kind of like a constant onslaught this
is a very high tier army another Dwarfs
their army costly the exact same they
have a lot of troops but they just
didn't hold very well my spells kind of
went off right so I got kind of lucky I
broke their jar bombed the jar bomb is
actually coming back in here to make a
quick run on my chaos Knights actually
comes in from me way knocks a few off
and then starts frantically dropping his
bomb
months ago chases and down oh that was
clever yes so here he is just going
along the line literally dropping the
bombs we see them actually coming over
the back my Manticore just isn't fast
enough together I always thought it'd be
really cool if Co like just like taking
a little walk out of the air with his
hunters but you can see just all the
carnage going on in the background
they're still holding their own like the
doors I'm just like yeah actually to
just get like the unit health of all my
units like it's it's quite low for the
chosen really low for the dragon ogres
and my collect himself is down the
halfway I'm taking more - so activated
them and augment their which speeds up
my Manticore which it'll allow me to
catch the the jar of honor right in the
sky yeah I love it next soda because
that sounds really good as well you can
just see the propellers like kind of
giving out nicely done
so I'm just kind of picking off who I
can't finishing off some writing units
bringing the manticore back into the
into the fray doing an amazing charges
into the unit's just take ripping them
apart basically this is kind of what you
have to feel the funny thing against
chaos or with them they're very very
strong and there's quite scary to be
honest I love seeing the dwarf like ants
the camera
yeah they just they're so little they
just like I did another final
transmutation again which is another
direct damage spell that was actually
something that really helped me getting
through in the beginning pushing through
their lungs that damage spell is an area
of effect space so you don't just target
one unit you target the area anyone
imitates the damage so that kind of
actually allowed me to hit five or six
tumors at once very very looking to get
it off with it was difficult to tell
because it still looks like they've got
so many units but you can see the
dwindling numbers of those units one of
the why don't have so many left yeah
they've got lots of kind of flags you
can see her as they're kind of they back
off and then they come back they kind of
reform but a lot because um grimace
actually fighting I mean not to mention
hungry and Iron Fist theory is here
getting up is after just being charged
but I've kind of left him alone for a
second I'm gonna bring in the shy guy
see he's gonna win in this fight very
well never turned it back to a joke they
took him down so he did pretty good also
I was told it's worth mentioning that
the fact he didn't react when he got hit
is because legendary Lords they do have
some react combinations for getting hit
they don't always react because if they
are constantly in the react state they
would never get an attack off it's kind
of a stun lock animation so that's
actually a choice made on purpose so
that the gameplay just flows a little
better and it's totally mentioned not by
the Dex
yeah so it's basically just ungroomed
left stubborn little guy doesn't want to
break I just kind of kind of envelop him
with everything that got he's taken out
you know the the shag off and collect
piss yeah you just surrounded him just
yeah just something everybody I think
because you know he's obviously gonna be
a bit Kolak actually hasn't a bum bark
at a bombardment spell of his own that I
called them as well it's called lord of
the storm it only lasts like five
seconds and it's it doesn't cost
anyone's a magical that's what the
animation there was where he lifts the
kind of accent or mace up in the air and
that's it was finished off by that oh
you've done it yeah so that's the
victory you know congratulations for
redeeming your title of not losing every
battle nice one Darren thank you very
much let us know what you think in the
comments down below and let us know what
you would like to see for future videos
like and subscribe for more thanks for
watching see it